We're going to review a proposition now.
If I ever tell you something in enough
detail that you've already heard that
you're like,
you've heard it enough,
please tell me because I can't.
I can't precisely remember what I told
you.
I know the line of the narrative
throughout the entire course and we will
return to some things fairly frequently,
but I don't want to tell you the same
story three times.
You know,
unless you're,
you know,
particularly compelled by that story,
so let me know.
I'm going to start with the proposition
and the proposition is that in order to
orient yourself properly in life,
there's two classes of information that
you have to have access to and one class
of information is information about the
nature of the object of world and the
object of world is described in a manner
or the world when it's treated
objectively.
Is it described in a manner that strips
all the subjectivity from it?
Right?
That's the technology that the
philosophical technology that's behind
the scientific revolution involve
stripping the subjectivity from,
from the sense mediated consequences of
certain kinds of actions.
Right?
Because when you lay on an experiment,
you're not just talking about what
happened,
you're talking about what you did and
then what happened,
and you're supposed to be able to do it
in a way that ensures that if someone
else followed exactly the same
procedure,
they would obviously observe the same
consequences and in some sense we're
trying to establish a realm of knowledge
that is universally applicable to people
despite their individual differences.
That's one way of thinking about it and
obviously that works.
Now,
whether or not it works in a Darwinian
sense,
we still have to determine because it
could easily be that our development of
the scientific method is what will make
us go extinct and which and under which
circumstances you might consider it to
have been an error,
but it doesn't really matter at the
moment because so far so good.
Roughly speaking.
So
now you know,
people think that the world is an
objective place because we can describe
it objectively and not so much more
debatable presupposition.
It's partly debatable because it's
actually based on a decision in some
sense rather than evidence.
Partly because your knowledge is finite
in every direction in some sense.
So what that means in a way is that no
matter what you know about anything,
you don't know everything about that
thing.
And so you kind of ground out in
ignorance at some point.
So what that means is that you have to
buttress your thinking with a set of
assumptions that you don't question or
you just ended up in an infinite
regress.
And one of those sets of assumptions is
usually reality sets of assumptions or
truth definitions,
sets of assumptions.
But the thing is generally,
no matter what your theory of reality is
or what your theory of truth is,
there are alternative theories of
reality and alternative theories of
truth that are equally rigorous and that
have different domains of application.
And it's a very tricky business.
So,
um,
so for example,
if you're a reductionist,
materialist,
you're going to make the presupposition
that a brain physiology is more real
than emotional experience.
And I suppose that's in some sense
because you can't get access to anyone
else's emotional experience,
at least not directly.
Whereas you can get universal access to
the fundamental details of someone's
brain physiology.
It's something like that anyways.
Now that still an arbitrary assumption
because obviously the person and you as
well are going to be acting all the time
as if your emotions and your motivation,
motivational states are real and so then
you run into a problem and the problem
is,
well,
how do you know what someone actually
believes?
Do you listen to what they say or or do
you take into account their explicit and
well articulated theories or do you
watch how they act?
And the answer to that is
you take your,
you make your choice,
and generally there are reasons for
that.
Now,
one of the,
one of the conceptual tools that I have
found helpful in my attempts to avoid
confusion when dealing with the fact
that there are very many ways of looking
at the world is to start thinking about
theories of reality as tools rather than
as descriptions.
And I find that extraordinarily useful
as a metaphor because you know you can.
If you have a toolbox full of tools,
you don't necessarily try to reduce the
utility of one tool to another and you
don't actually complain because all the
tools aren't the same.
You know,
a ranch isn't a very good hammer,
but that doesn't mean you can criticize
it on that grounds.
It's,
you might not want to use it as a
hammer,
although you could I suppose,
but it's not justifiable criticism and
it looks to me,
and this is something a psychologist
named George Kelly pointed out as well,
although I think it's also an element of
pragmatic philosophy,
is that I'm
one set of tools for one thing and
another set of tools for another thing
and that's helpful.
That's helpful.
And so,
and then you know,
you are also thinking about the sorts of
problems that you like solve with
different forms of tools and one problem
is what are things made of in an
objective sense,
let's say.
And then another problem might be,
well what is the landscape of
experience?
And that's more of a phenomenological
problem.
That's the problem the phenomenologists
set out.
And then the other problem might be how
do you and should you conduct yourself,
and it could easily be that you can't
use the same tool to solve all those
problems.
And I would say that's particularly true
technically when you're dealing with
science because science by its very
nature,
refuses to answer questions about what
it is that you should do apart from some
implicit assumption that you should do
science,
which is actually not,
well,
that's actually not a scientific
assumption by the way,
because it's a moral assumption.
And the moral assumption is that if you
conduct yourself in a scientific manner,
things would be better,
right?
Because why would you run around doing
science to make things worse?
Although you absolutely you can,
you absolutely can.
And,
and we perhaps we are,
you know,
and,
and even if we aren't,
we still might.
So,
so what's one of the things that I find
quite interesting about the scientific
endeavor,
and this is something you observed,
was that it has to be nested in
something outside of itself to give it
its motive force.
It has to be nested in a system of moral
assumptions and the fundamental moral
assumption is the world will be a better
place if we conduct ourselves along
scientific lines because otherwise why
do it?
And that's a statement that cannot be
analyzed from within the confines of the
scientific worldview because it doesn't
analyze those sorts of questions.
Now you could say they're not real,
but that's a stupid answer because I
think it's,
it's a,
it's a cop out.
Maybe it's not a stupid answer,
probably yes,
but at least it's a cop out because you,
if you don't take that question
seriously,
you can't really justify engaging in the
activity and so you can refuse to answer
it,
but you're basically answering it by
engaging in the activity anyway.
So even if you're not saying it,
you're still justifying it.
Alright.
So you know,
so I'm assuming that you can draw
conclusions from people's actions like
you can from their statements and it's
hard really to dispute that.
I would say if you're wise.
In fact,
I think you derive conclusions from
their actions then from their
statements.
So.
Okay,
so that's,
that's the under belly of the first
proposition and the first,
the development of that is something
like the means by which information is
transmitted that is relevant to the
domain of behavior is not the same means
by which it's transmitted by which
scientific information is transmitted
and we kind of know that too,
you know,
without any real debate I believe
because how old do you think science is
as a technical endeavor?
What would you estimate?
Okay.
Hundreds of years,
maybe thousands of years if you're
willing to give it the Greeks some
credit,
but really probably not.
Probably hundreds because I ever
stopped.
Aristotle wasn't a scientist,
like he wasn't a bad observer,
but he certainly wasn't empirical
observer and no one got science
straightened out.
Dylan's probably what Newton Descartes
Bacon and you know,
there's a handful of other characters
who were,
who were thinking around those that
period of time and they sort of,
you know,
establish the proper methods really.
And also the philosophy that underlies
not very old,
600 years,
you know,
500 years,
man,
that's really nothing.
It's the blink of an eye.
It's yesterday.
If that,
it might even be like an hour ago,
it's,
it's nothing,
but obviously people were transmitting
information about how to act to each
other for untold millennia before that
and it's probably more like,
it depends on what you're willing to
consider transmission of information,
but even Octopi can imitate,
you know,
and so they're the smartest
invertebrates.
They're quite bright.
Those things,
they're not exactly sure how smart.
They only live a couple of years so they
can't really get things going,
you know,
but they can problem solve.
They can pull carts out of bottles to
get like a crab in a bottle.
And then if they watch an octopus,
an octopus watches another octopus,
pull the cork out of a bottle to get a
tasty crab,
then that octopus now knows how to do
it.
So which is pretty impressive.
And you can kind of see why occupied
might be able to do that because not
only do they have a brain,
but they have little technically
appendages which allow them to
manipulate things.
Right.
And so one of the pre cursors to being
able to be intelligent in any active way
is that you have to have tentatively
appendages so that you can manipulate
the world,
right?
And at least for it to be anything
resembling what we would consider
intelligence.
And that's part of the reason that
dolphins really art as intelligent as
people like to think because what are
they going to do?
You can't build cities with their
flippers,
you know,
they are kind of trapped in their test,
two bodies and the same thing applies to
whale.
So obviously they have very large brains
and they're very social and they can
learn and,
but whatever their intelligence is,
it's not like our intelligence because
we run around tearing things apart and
putting them back together.
We've got the body for that.
So.
Alright.
So anyways,
long before we were practicing science,
we were doing perfectly well in a sense
without any real knowledge of the
objective world at all,
or at least not in scientific knowledge
of the objective world.
And so another thing that you might
observe about that is that you can
survive perfectly well without knowing
any science at all or in an articulated
and developed manner.
Of course animals are in that category.
So that also I think in some sense
undermines the claim of science to
anything approaching a universal truth
because obviously life can get along
perfectly well without it now.
It depends to some degree on whether
you're a Darwinian or a Newtonian
comments on what people should do.
This more feature of modern science than
it is a science in general because I'm
thinking like someone like,
I don't know if he knows,
I don't know.
Okay,
well if it's his maxim,
is that basically it's wrong always for
anyone everywhere to believe anything on
his evidence.
And he sort of says that he's a
mathematician who tries to prove it on
a,
on a moral basis.
Of course it's still not scientific
because that kind of claim can't really
be signed.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean obviously the people who began
the scientific revolution thought of it
as part of a moral movement,
right?
I mean,
it was part of the enlightenment that
was part of bringing clarity to our
conceptualizations of the world and that
was supposed to be a positive thing,
but you know,
the only,
the only issue is,
is that claim seems to be outside of the
claim of science in some sense.
So anyways,
you get the picture with regards to the
argument.
Okay,
so now the next step might be,
well,
if you need or can utilize or there
exists information that is not strictly
scientific,
one might be,
well where did that information come
from?
That that's a good one.
How is it transmitted?
That's another one and the worst of it
is of course is how might it be
verified,
you know,
because one of the issues,
one of the things that scientists have
really got down and it's a major deal,
is that they can lay forth at theory of
truth and then they can operate within
that theory of truth and pretty much
everybody can agree on what it is now.
And the more well established the
science,
the more that's the case.
So like people don't really doubt
Einstein's.
People already don't doubt quantum
theory anymore and you guys don't doubt
it because there you are using your
computers and you wouldn't be able to
use your computers if quantum theory
wasn't right,
so you know it's right.
Certainly right enough,
but even more impressively than not,
what?
Whenever someone has tried to prove it
wrong in any possible way,
even if it's more most bizarre
predictions over the last hundred and
some years,
it's passed every test with flying
colors.
So you know you can make pretty damn
solid truth claims from within the
scientific perspective.
Now the problem is it's a lot harder to
do that from within a moral perspective
and there's all sorts of reasons for
that.
And one reason might be that there is a
certain amount of situational complexity
related to every moral question that you
can't reduce.
So for example,
imagine that you're a clinical
psychologist and you're listening.
I've been in this situation and you're
listening to two people who know each
other very well.
Maybe a husband and wife,
um,
discuss their last argument.
And you might say,
well,
you might think,
well let's get to the bottom of this.
Let's find out what this argument is
about.
And you might think if you were
scientifically inclined that it is in
fact about something,
which means that if you investigated
long enough you can actually figure out
what the facts are.
But I actually don't believe that's
true.
And the reason I don't believe it's true
is this.
So imagine,
imagine you have.
There's this old joke about these two
friends,
like they're,
they're like 85 years old and they're
sitting on a park bench feeding the
pigeons and one friend says to the other
64 and the other guy cracks up and
laughs like mad about that.
And then the other guy says 83 and the
other guy cracks up and laughed like mad
about that.
And somebody watching them and wondering
what in the world is going on?
And so the person comes over and says to
these old guys,
well,
what's the scope here?
You,
all you're doing there is sitting there
saying memories to each other.
And then you're laughing uproariously.
I mean,
I,
I just don't get it.
And they say,
well,
we've known each other for so long that
we've heard each other's jokes at least
100 times and so we have them completely
memorized.
So a couple of years ago we decided we
just numbered the damn things and it
would take a lot less time to tell them
and you know,
we,
we could laugh more of that.
And so,
okay.
So,
so it's an interesting little joke,
you know,
because it shed some light on the nature
of deep relationships and if you have a
deep relationship with them,
with someone while here's how you can
think about it.
Imagine you're trying to analyze an
essay.
Now I've actually built an essay writing
module which is on my site to 30
website.
It's,
I don't remember which template it is,
but I'll tell you in a while,
it's based on this theory of meaning,
roughly speaking,
and you should use it to write your
essay because if you do,
it'll be a way better essay.
So here's the,
here's the issue,
when you're reading an essay,
where is the meaning?
Well that's a hard one because first of
all it might be in many places.
That's.
So the question might be badly
formulated in some sense because it
might be at many places.
So let,
let's,
let's think it through logically.
Well you need the letters if it's an
alphabetic,
if it's written in alphabetic script and
so obviously some of the meeting is in
the letters and then the letters are
combined in certain particular ways and
that gives you some words and then the
words are combined in some particular
ways and that gives you phrases and the
phrases are joined together in sentences
and then the sentences are strung
together in some reasonably coherent
manner.
So they kind of go from start to end in
a paragraph and then the paragraphs are
strung together in a coherent manner to
make up the totality of the essay.
And then one of the things I've noticed
when I've been trying to figure out how
to grade essays and how to assess them
is that you can do a good or a bad job
at any one of those levels.
So like a really bad essay.
It's full of spelling mistakes,
right?
The words are inappropriate because the
person doesn't actually understand them,
so they're awkwardly used.
The phrases are put together in a
cliched manner.
The sentence structure isn't good.
The sentences aren't even in the write
paragraphs,
much less organized properly.
The paragraphs don't flow from one to
another in what might be called the.
That's kind of where the skeleton of the
story is.
It's sort of the most important level in
some sense.
And then even if that wasn't all wrong,
there's actually no idea there anyways.
And then you can also read essays that
have one or more of those flaws or or
you know,
some combination of all of them.
So very frequently I read a student's
essay and this often happens with smart
creative students who are very badly
educated and that would be probably
50 percent of the people in this class.
I would bet,
and I say that for genuine reasons
because I run a fourth year seminar
where I have people write extensively
and so what they do is they write a four
page essay and then I complained about
it and and all those levels of analysis
and then they write the same,
see again in six pages and then I do the
same thing and then they write the same
essay and eight pages and the first half
of the first essays are terrible and you
know that's partly because students do
you try out as triaged,
right?
They think,
well,
do I really have to work in this course?
I'll work a bit and see what happens and
if I get slapped and I'll work a little
harder and if I don't then I can devote
my time to other courses.
Which is a perfectly reasonable thing to
do.
But some of it's just pure inability.
But what's really fascinating is that by
the end of the course,
all of the students are writing well and
it's pathetic as far as I'm concerned
because it meant that everybody could
have been taught to write 10 years ago,
but they just weren't.
So anyways,
if you look at this template that I laid
out,
then it will help you with this because
it walks you through the process of
writing property and that's an
extraordinarily useful thing to be able
to do.
So anyways,
so,
so now and then I'll read an essay and
everything is wrong about it,
but there's a really smart idea in it.
And then knowing this multilevel idea
with regards to meaning,
I could say,
look,
you know,
you're smarter than you can,
right?
And so there's really something here,
but you know,
here's all the things that are wrong
with it.
But,
and then you get a worse situation in
some sense where everything about the
essay is good,
but the idea isn't.
And so the words are good and the
phrases to sentences are right that it
goes together,
but it adds up to nothing.
And those are tough to grade because you
give them a c maybe or b,
because I probably give them a b and the
person comes up and says,
where did I make a mistake?
It's like,
well,
you didn't really make a mistake,
you just didn't do anything.
Right.
You know?
And,
and that's,
that's a whole different problem
anyways.
Okay.
So you think that's pretty complex with
regards to an essay?
Where's the meaning?
But that isn't where the meaning is.
So here,
let me,
let me give you an example.
I was thinking about this the other day.
So the ethnicity and the cultural
backgrounds of my students have changed
quite radically over the years.
Right.
And so when I started teaching this
course,
for example,
and my personality course as well,
which would have been 30 years ago,
I can take it for granted that everybody
in the room with no the basic biblical
stories and they would know the Judeo
Christian version of the.
Not say the Islam version of them.
Well that's gone.
And so that's really,
that's really made it difficult for me
in some ways because there's a bunch of
things.
There's a bunch of collective knowledge
that might constitute a shared set of
cultural assumptions that I can no
longer presume and it means there's all
sorts of things that I either can't talk
about or if I'm going to talk about I
have to step way back and start from
start from first principles let's say,
and so that's also made me think so
because if I.
let's say you write me an essay and
let's say it's a psychology essay,
okay,
now you're going to presume that there's
a whole bunch of things I know about
psychology that you also know and the
reason you're going to presume that is
because we're.
We come from,
we're for the purpose of this
conversation.
We're going to come from the same
cultural background and what that means
is we,
we share a set of assumptions and we
don't have to say what those assumptions
are.
We can assume them and then we can talk
about the things that we disagree about.
And of course that's what you're doing
when you're writing an essay.
We're having a conversation right here.
You're saying,
well obviously you and have to talk
about what we know because we already
know it.
We want to push that a little bit so we
start to talk a little bit about the
things that we don't know,
but no more so than we both understand.
So then you think,
well damn it,
the meaning of the essay isn't in the
essay at all.
It's in the interaction between the
shared cultural assumptions of the
writer and the reader and the asset.
Well,
and then you think,
well,
it's worse than that even because the
shared cultural assumptions are into
their own sort of network and then
that's nested inside of it.
Very broad historical network and then
that's nested inside an extraordinarily
broad biological network and it's like
actually you can continue expanding the
outer reaches of the essay without limit
and so part of that means it's actually
impossible to specify the meaning of the
essay.
It's something that you both work at in
combination as writer and as a reader,
but it's very fluid and flexible and
that's that problem is actually partly
why the postmodernist Scott going
because they sort of noticed this,
I mean corrupt as they are.
They did notice at one point that it was
very,
very difficult to say what any given
phrase paragraph or even essay meant
because it wasn't in that it wasn't
there.
Like it's not in the book.
It's sort of in the book.
But you know this too.
If you listen,
you know,
you listen to a piece of music,
you know.
So let's say you had a favorite song
when you were 14,
you know,
and when you first heard that,
so I'm maybe you didn't like it that
much,
but then you heard it four times and you
think,
man,
that's one excellent song.
And then at some point you've heard it
so many times if you never want to hear
it again.
And it's.
And that's interesting too because it
means the song has transformed in
relationship to your historical,
in interactions with it.
You might say,
well no,
the song is the same.
It's like,
well,
it depends on what you mean by the song,
the notes or the same experiences.
Certainly transport.
So.
Okay,
so anyways,
back to the couple that are sitting
there talking.
They're having this argument,
they're trying to sort out what this is
about and the problem is,
well,
it's about everything that the argument
is about plus everything that's ever
happened to them in their relationship
because you know,
if someone has told you the same thing
50 times,
it is not the same thing as the thing
they told you the first time,
right?
God only knows how many transformations
it's gone through as it's been
continually repeated and how many
different arguments it's been embedded
in and and how many things you have to
know to understand the shades of
intonation and all of that,
but basically each other instead a
couple of producers is,
is it's meaning as determined by the
entire history of interactions that
those two people have had and so how do
you,
how are you going to specify that?
It's very,
very difficult to specify it.
Now you really can,
and it's also difficult to know when
you've specified it enough,
you know,
so one of the things that's interesting
about training as a psychoanalyst is
that
it's it.
It starts to become an absolutely mind
boggling how much archeology you can do,
you can undertake underneath a single
statement,
especially if it's delivered with a bit
of an edge and some contempt.
It's like there are just levels and
levels and levels and levels and levels
of meaning underneath that.
And you can tell that when you're
engaged in an argument like that because
someone will trigger you,
let's say for lack of a better word and
you know,
they'll have broken a rule that you've
established with them and you're both in
a pit and you know,
the fight is about that path.
Even though maybe it's about some
surface thing and you're just running
around.
They're like racks that are lit on fire
and there's nothing you can do about it.
You know,
and it's,
it's,
it's a consequence of all the issues
that are lurking beneath the surface of
that speech act.
That seemed to be something you can
capture it on video.
You'd say,
well,
here's what you said,
there's a video tape recording them.
It's like,
no,
that's not what you said,
because the videotape does not capture
the context and it can't,
so you can't even get an objective
record of the meaning of a conversation
because the meaning isn't right in the
conversation.
So okay,
so that's one of the problems.
One of the problems with trying to
validate moral claims is that you've got
this insane contextual complexity that's
almost impossible to dispose up and so
you could say,
you could even say that if person a did
action a in situation a,
that would be right and a person beaded
action a and situation a that would be
wrong and it depends on the person and
so it's very easy to slip from that into
a kind of moral relativism because how
in the world do you deal with the
complexity and how do you make a truth
claim?
And so I would really say in some sense
that's this intellectual situation in
modern universities.
Now,
the other thing that's kind of
interesting is this was actually
discovered in a number of different
fields simultaneously,
so just as the literary theorists
started to discover,
say,
after World War II that it was really,
it wasn't enough to say that a book has
meaning in it,
that there's something wrong with that
and that there isn't a single meeting.
There's a multiplicity of meanings and
it's not even a stable multiplicity of
meanings.
People were finding that out in in other
domains as well.
For example,
in artificial intelligence where it
became very,
very obvious very rapidly that
perceiving a simple object was not
simple because objects aren't sample and
the border between one object and
another is in some sense arbitrary,
right?
I mean,
when I look at each of you,
I sort of see you as entities,
right?
But that's because I see you at this
level of resolution.
You know,
your cellular masses at a different
level of resolution,
your molecular composites at a different
level of resolution.
There are 10 times you're made up of 10
times as many bacteria as cells at
another level of resolution.
So really you're more like an ocean,
then you are like an entity and then
well is it you or your family,
that's the real or is it you,
your family and your culture?
What about your species or you know,
or are you a mammal?
It's like
all of those things and all of those
things and any of those things at the
same time.
And so when I look at you,
what am I supposed to see?
You know,
do I see individual with name or do I
see ethnicity or dyc?
Well,
you get the picture.
So object perception turns out to be
extraordinarily difficult because things
aren't just simple objects,
even if they're relatively simple.
Alright?
So
you throw up your hands,
you think,
well,
how can there ever be any harmony?
How can you draw any sense out of that?
Okay,
so that's the argument against drawing
any sense out of it.
But then let's,
let's try the other tack.
Let's see if we can make a case for
there being some sense to the claims of,
of that,
that moral claims can be validated.
Okay?
So here's a question for you.
If you took a bunch of chimpanzees that
didn't know each other and you threw
them in this classroom,
what you would have is a war right now,
you're roughly in that situation.
Not exactly because,
hey,
you're not chimpanzees,
but you know,
your genetic material is quite
reasonably related.
Um,
I mean,
you only split off your common ancestor
7 million years ago and that seems like
a long time in a day,
but it's not 300 million years ago.
You know,
it's still relatively recently from the
evolutionary perspective here.
You all are.
You don't really know each other.
You obviously share important elements
of identity.
So you're all students,
but you can come in here and all of a
sudden you all know what to do and no
one,
no one fights or if they do fight,
it's,
there are very constrained rules around
the fighting and everyone accepts them.
And it seems hard to say that that's not
better than the alternative.
So you know,
unless you want to come in here and have
an APP still chaotic
war.
So somehow we've managed to figure out
how we can at least brings relative
strangers together in a relatively high
pressure situation because we were
learning about complicated and
challenging things and everybody gets
along and everybody's kind of happy
about that.
So it looks like we can figure out
patterns of behavior that.
Well then the question is,
are they correct,
are they morally correct or they write
or do they work?
And then you might also ask yourself,
well,
what's the difference between all of
those claims?
Is there a similarity or difference
between those claims?
So,
and then you might ask yourself,
okay,
so here,
here's something else you might think
about.
So
let's say you're playing monopoly.
How many of you have played monopoly in
your life?
Okay,
is there anyone here who hasn't played
monopoly?
Excellent.
A cultural universal.
So I'm obviously in some ways it doesn't
matter if you get all those little
hotels right?
Okay.
But on the other hand,
if you act like it doesn't matter while
you're playing monopoly,
then people hit you with things and they
should.
Because part of the rule is you're gonna
act like this matters because if you
don't,
then it's not any fun.
So you have to act like in Madison.
Then it turns out that when you start
playing it backs right,
and people will actually,
they'll get angry,
especially if you achieved,
you know,
but people will play monopoly so they'll
act as if the end point matters.
And you might say,
well,
what is the end point?
And one answer is to get all the hotels
and all the money,
so to enter the one percent,
so you have all the wealth and no one
has any and you win and you feel happy
about that even if you're a radical left
winger.
So that's kind of interesting.
And so,
and uh,
and then you say,
well,
that's not really the point.
The point is to enjoy the game and you
think,
yeah,
okay.
That's probably the point too.
Um,
and then you might say,
well that's not really the point either.
It's like you want to,
you want to know holding your
negotiating skills.
Do you want to spend some time with your
friends?
Like there's lots of things going on at
once and so,
but it doesn't really matter because
monopoly is a game that you'll play.
Okay?
Now imagine instead that monopoly.
Here's the new rule for monopoly.
All the people you're playing with can
randomly steal your hotels and houses
and your money whenever they want and
you can steal it back.
Okay,
so then you think,
well
no one's gonna play that game,
and then you think,
well why not?
Well,
the first surface answers,
that's a stupid game.
Okay,
but and you know that somehow you think
that's a stupid game,
but then you starting to think about,
well why is that a stupid game?
Or you might say it's not unplayable
gate,
which would be a little bit more
sophisticated.
It's like why?
Why would that not work?
And you might say,
well what's the point in getting the
hotels if someone can just take them,
but you might say what's the point?
And getting the whole deal is anyway.
It's like,
who cares about the damn hotel?
It's,
it's a bit tricky.
There's something about the randomness
of the,
of what's now allowed and the
unpredictability of it and the arbitrary
nature of it and its lack of a
relationship with your own actions that
takes all the motivational impotence out
of the gate.
So one thing we might think about to
begin with is there's a difference
between a good game and a bad game and
there's also a difference between a game
and no gate and we don't know what the
difference is exactly,
but there is a difference and then we
might even say,
well,
not only are there good games and bad
games,
but some good games are better than
other games.
How many of you have played settlers of
Catan?
Okay.
Is that better than monopoly or worse?
It's better.
It's anybody think it's not better?
Okay.
Why is it better?
What's better about it?
It's more complex and heard what you
said.
We're not necessarily stealing,
but there's a piece of the gay whether
it was
or something like that.
Yeah,
there's a robber.
Place him on one of the titles.
Again,
you can mess with people essentially.
So that's fun.
It is just like,
I'm going to get you with this,
Robert.
It's more akin to like real life,
I think.
Like in monopoly.
No,
that's reasonable.
That's reasonable.
It's also got a strategic element.
How many of you played risk?
Okay.
Settlers of a Katana risk
settlers.
Who says risk to risk to risk diehards.
What about the rest of you?
How many for risk?
How many first?
Settlers of Catan.
Okay.
So well,
settlers of Katana is quite a bit like
risk because it has a strategic element.
Right?
And there's a territorial expansion that
goes along with it and there's also
trading,
which is one of the things that's nice
about monopoly and about risk.
Okay.
But so you can see that you have
intuitions about what constitutes a
better game and part of the way that you
develop those intuitions is not exactly
philosophically because I doubt if you
really thought through white settlers of
Cape Town is a better game say than risk
or monopoly.
For those of you that think it is,
but you aren't your own reaction and
your own reaction is something like,
well,
I'd rather play settlers of kc tap and
you might ask yourself why,
but you don't have to.
You can just rather play it and then so
what?
And then you think,
well,
what does it mean that you'd rather play
it and you'd say,
wow,
it's more fun.
It's more enjoyable if asked
voluntarily,
that's the one I would pick,
but you don't really know why apart from
those reasons,
but obviously those are complex.
That's a complex social engagement.
Those games that are complex and and in
fact they're so complex that you can
have preferences and not even know why.
Now that's interesting and I think the
idea that there are games,
good games and bad games and games,
a non games is a nice way of starting to
conceptualize what the difference might
be doing between moral systems because
the game is actually a moral system,
right?
It,
it,
it has a point.
It has an end.
You have to cooperate and compete to,
to run through the gate.
So awhile back,
a psychologist actually started this and
and,
and it's reprehensible,
but psychologists have done lots of
reprehensible things and this is one of
them,
he this psychologist whose name I don't
remember that moment was reviewing the
literature on the difference in
aggression between boys and girls and
men and women and
boys and men are much more aggressive
depending on how you define aggressive
than girls and women.
Now that tends to be mostly true with
physical aggression.
So you might say kicking,
hitting,
biting,
punching,
stealing,
two year old boys for example,
the ones who do two year olds,
the ones who do most of that,
or boys now,
the two year old girls are a kind of
each other up behind their backs,
but no one measures that.
Right?
And so you find,
for example,
with female aggression,
it tends to be relationship savaging and
you see that on the,
in the playground,
you see it in junior high,
you see it in high school and you see it
on the net.
It's always the same thing.
So whether men are more aggressive than
women is,
depends on how you define aggression.
But men are more physically aggressive
anyways.
Um,
a while back there was this idea that
maybe we could dampen down to male
aggression by socializing little boys,
more like little girls.
So,
and,
and one of the offshoots of that was the
idea that we should only allow children
to play cooperative games.
Now,
the first thing you might notice is that
anything you've ever done that was a
game was not cooperative,
right?
Like it's not a game if it's just
cooperative.
But then the other thing you might
notice is that the distinction between a
cooperative in a competitive game is far
more sophisticated than people who come
up with those dimwitted theories about
how to improve the world,
whatever.
Appreciate.
So here's an example.
Hockey game.
Yes.
Is it an aggressive gate?
Is it a competitive game?
Is it a cooperative game?
Ha.
Why?
Why is it a cooperative game together?
Right?
So there's the team,
right?
So you're obviously cooperating with
your team members,
but you're also maybe trying to be the
best player,
but you're also trying to be the best
player in a way that doesn't irritate
the hell out of your team players.
Right?
Because that's actually,
there's something about that that's
counterproductive.
Like even if you're a good player,
if you're a prima donna and you hug the
park,
say,
and you know,
you know,
maybe you're not interested in the
development of your other team members.
Like you're not a good player even if
you're the most talented.
So there's definitely a cooperative
element.
Is there a cooperative element beyond
that?
Well,
yeah,
you have to all agree to sort of
cooperating in so much as um,
you know,
agreeing to the rules of the game and
playing with it.
You don't bring a chess board or
basketball right now,
no matter if you're on different teams,
right?
Because you're all there to play hockey.
So just to play hockey as a cooperative
endeavor,
because think of all the other things
you could be doing instead of playing
hockey at that time,
you could be doing an infinite number of
other things.
So really if you look at the
relationship between cooperation and
competition in any collaborative human
affair,
things are usually competitive at one
level,
cooperative and another competitive at
another.
Like there's this continual interplay
between competition and cooperation and
you can't disentangle them.
Now,
one of the things that Piaget said,
which Piaget's is,
for those of you who don't own you
probably all do now,
is perhaps the foremost developmental
psychologist of the 20th century,
even though he didn't think he was a
psychologist,
um,
piaget actually made the claim the
radical claim that two year olds for
example,
and this isn't Psj is clean,
but if it's associated,
if you put groups of people together and
their age matched.
So you got a group of nine months olds,
say one year olds,
two year olds,
three year olds,
four year olds,
all the way up to 18,
and you just throw them in a room maybe
with some things for them to do,
and then you count the number of violent
acts which is kicking,
hitting,
biting or stealing.
Okay.
Two year olds,
they're the most violent human beings
and most of them are actually aren't
violent.
There's a subset of them that are
violence,
about five to 10 percent of them.
Now almost all of those are boys.
And then if you track those boys across
time,
over the next two years,
most of them become civilized and the
ones that don't never become civilized.
And then so they're kind of antisocial
throughout their childhood.
And then when testosterone kicks in at
about 14 and all the boys get antisocial
again,
they catch up to the always antisocial
boys.
And then the normal boys taper off quite
dramatically at around 19 and flattened
right out by about 27.
But the antisocial boys,
they just keep being antisocial.
So now piaget noted that there was a
dramatic transformation in,
in,
in behavior or individual behavior in
relationship to the social world between
the ages of two and four.
And if you watch two year olds play
together,
he said that what they did fundamentally
it was like a parallel play.
So maybe there's one,
two year old there and another two year
old there and that two year old is
playing truck and this two year old is
playing ambulance or something or maybe
playing doll and they're sitting with
each other and maybe they interact a
little bit,
but they're not playing the same game.
Okay.
So,
so what they're doing in some senses,
they're engaged in a goal directed
activity.
It and it has a point and they're
trying.
They're sort of integrating all their
interior subpersonalities in sense in a
way that allows them to play a single
game with themselves.
You know?
And that's pretty complex from a
cognitive perspective,
right?
Because it means there's not,
they're not fractionated and they're not
being pulled out by hunger or anger or
sadness or fear or any of those things.
And they're doing something that's
highly complex cognitively and they can
make an organized themselves well enough
to do it for a substantial period of
time.
So it's like it's a major developmental
advance,
but they can't do it with another
person.
Now,
one of Piaget's hypotheses was that they
couldn't do it do.
They couldn't play the same game with
another person without actually setting
up a competitive structure so that
actually compete.
Competition was a prerequisite to
cooperation.
And so the idea was,
okay,
so if you watch how kids do this,
you can get a sense of it.
I mean on the one hand,
maybe they,
they all get together and they decided
to play tag.
Okay?
And everyone knows the rules for tag and
you can win at 10,
but without the point,
the point in some senses,
the construction of a dominance
hierarchy of competence,
right?
Someone wins.
And then there's the people who are sort
of second best and third best and
everybody's really into doing that.
You all have to get together.
If your kids and you say,
well what should we do?
And then he decided we're going to play
tag.
And then you set up the rules because
there's infinite variations of tag and
then everyone goes off in place and so
it's a competitive game because only one
person can win or maybe one at a time
can win.
But once you've all agreed on that,
well then you're cooperating.
So,
so that's quite interesting in Psj
regarded that as necessary stage in the
development of the ability to act like a
social creature.
And then.
And so here's,
here's something that happens if you're
not a very popular kid.
So let's say for kids that are playing
jacks good enough,
I don't think kids play jacks anymore,
but whatever,
if they were playing jocks,
they're are sitting there playing jacks
and when you play jokes,
you bounce a ball and you pick up a jock
and manage that and the ball because you
manage that.
Then you drop the ball and you pick up
to Jackson,
you grew up the ball and you keep going
up to like eight jacks or whatever.
So now another kid wants to play Jacks
and we'll say this is a relatively
popular kid.
And so the kids sidles up to the group
that's playing and sits down because
they're all sitting down and then
watches and then maybe starts making
jack playing motions are a couple of
comments about how the Jac game is going
and then maybe the other kids don't have
to disrupt what they're doing very much
and they can kind of open the circle and
let that kid scoot in and then he gets
to her,
she gets to play Jacks to whereas a kid
that doesn't.
And that often doesn't happen.
Even if it's a popular kid,
sometimes the little group that's
already formed won't open.
And let the man you've been at cocktail
parties.
It's exactly the same thing,
right?
It's exactly the same thing.
She was supposed to hang around the edge
of the conversation and maybe if you've
got something that isn't too stupid to
say you can offer it,
then maybe they'd let you in.
Right?
So,
okay,
so now if you're not very social,
what you do is you stand out there and
you don't notice what the hell's going
on and you don't start to match your
body to what's happening.
And maybe you say,
I know want to play Jacks,
that's a stupid game.
Let's go do something else.
In which case the kids are not happy
with you and your unpopular and that's
that you're stuck with it.
Because if you got that by the time of
year for about the other kids are going
to leave you so far in the dust,
you're never going to catch up.
Okay?
So,
so what have,
what have we concluded from that?
We might conclude that
people play games.
There's lots of different games.
Um,
there's lots of different playable
games.
There might even be an infinite number
of playable games.
There's a lot of non playable games.
Those are the ones that aren't any fun.
And there's a lot of interactions that
aren't games.
Okay?
So we can all accept that.
And then we've added to that the
observation or the presupposition that
the ability to play games is a
prerequisite for being socialized.
So being able to operate together with
people and that that operation has
elements of competition and elements of
cooperation reasonable.
And then you might say,
well,
everything people do communally has a
game like aspect,
and you might say,
well that's actually why kids like to
play games because kids play games
because games are a simplified analog of
life.
And if you get good at playing games,
well what happens is the games you play
become increasingly complex and more and
more real world,
like until they're actually
indistinguishable from acting in the
world,
but they're even then they're still
games in a sense because they could.
The rules could be different.
But then what?
But then you might think,
well,
are there things that couldn't be
different?
And yeah,
there are some things.
It's going to be cooperative,
it's going to be competitive,
there's going to be ruled.
Everybody needs to agree on the rules.
People have to want to play.
This is something else piaget observed.
It's bloody brilliant.
He thought,
well,
how could you decide if one game is
better than another?
And that's a moral,
let's say that it's a moral claim in a
sense.
Okay.
But he wanted to narrow it down so that
it was possible that it could be
answered,
and what he said was,
okay,
well imagine you have group a that are
attempting to attain a goal and Group B
that are attempting to attain a goal.
Both groups have agreed that attaining
the goal is valuable.
We don't have to argue about the value
of the goal.
We've settled that,
okay,
now we're going to make a further
assumption,
which is all things considered getting
towards the goal with less effort,
more enjoyment,
and less trouble would be better.
Okay.
You have to take that as a given because
it might not be.
Sometimes something difficult is better,
but well then you might say,
okay,
would people working voluntarily or
involuntarily be more likely to reach
that goal with less misery faster and
more effectively?
And Piaget's answer was,
if you can get people to play the game
voluntarily,
you don't have to waste any effort on
enforcement.
No one kicks back.
So the system is to be more efficient
across time.
Now that's,
that's smart because he's gone,
he's gone on way of conceptualizing what
might constitute a better system.
Now it's grounded in subjective
experience to some degree,
less misery,
more enjoyment.
Um,
but there's also a way of measuring it,
which is also more efficient,
you know,
or it does what it's supposed to do with
less noise and grief,
less costs,
let's say.
Something like that.
So that's,
that's pretty smart.
Okay.
So then let's,
let's make another.
Well,
hmm.
How old do you think kids games are
like,
and I don't know what's happened to kids
in recent years because their,
their culture in some ways has been
seriously disrupted by television and
computers,
but you guys are a lot younger than me.
Did you play hide and go seek?
Okay.
Do you know ring around the Rosie?
You know that?
Do you know what that is?
You don't know when you're on the road.
So how many people don't know that that
ring around the rosy pocket full of
posies hotshot?
How shall we all fall down?
Okay.
How many know that?
Okay,
it's an English nursery rhyme.
It's about the play.
It's about the black plate by the way,
and so that piece of dog role,
that piece of Ryan has been around
transmitted by the oral cultural
children since the time of the black
plague.
And so a lot of co children's tradition
is an oral tradition and a lot of the
games that children play are passed
along.
My children,
you know,
adults might also teach them,
but kids learn how to play hide and go
seek.
And how many of you played tag?
Right?
Ever.
Anyone never played tag,
right?
So everyone plays tag.
What,
how would you conceptualize tag if you
were a biologist?
What do you think children are doing?
They're hunting,
right?
They're chasing things down.
Obviously they're chasing things down
now.
Hide and go seek.
Well that's a tougher one,
but it certainly exploration.
They're exploring the landscape,
right?
And they're matching wits against one
another,
but then they're also trying to see if,
you know,
do people like you enough to actually
find you,
which is a helpful thing to know if
you're four years old.
So anyways,
children past these games down across,
let's say across the centuries,
and maybe tag is one of those games that
you wouldn't even have to pass down.
Children might just invented
spontaneously with every generation like
because you can more or less play tag
with a dog,
you know,
I mean the dog doesn't quite get it but,
but,
but it's close.
Okay.
So.
So there are some games that are,
that are enjoyable and now so that
they're,
they're either transmitted and everyone
learns some very rapidly or they're,
they're so close to our nature that we
can reinvent them.
And Tag I think is the classic example
of that.
So.
So that's interesting too because what
it means is that there are certain types
of competitive and cooperative behavior.
Those are elementary moral systems that
are.
They look like they're integral to our
nature.
Now.
You could even say they're built right
or you could say there are so close to
built in that it doesn't take much of a
introduction to the rules of the game
before.
Everybody's pretty happy with it.
And you know,
you see this with a lot of things.
You play peekaboo with a baby.
Okay?
So what are the rules?
What are the rules of peekaboo?
What's that?
You Go,
you cover your eyes.
He.
Okay,
so that's right.
So you go like this.
Okay.
Then what's the next rule?
That's right.
You reveal your eyes.
You don't just sit there like this.
Now you know you can play a trick on her
baby if you want.
And babies will laugh about this sort of
thing,
which is really,
I think really quite amazing.
The baby's laugh is something remarkable
to me.
So you can go like this and then like
this and then like this and then like
this.
And then you can do this new baby will
laugh because that's,
that's a little variation.
A or you can go like this,
right?
And then the baby,
while even that'll even make you guys
can see how deeply rooted this is.
So you know,
but eventually one of the baby do it.
They'll grab your hands,
right?
Pull them down because you're breaking
the dam rules.
Maybe knows the rules.
Even though you've never established any
rules and you can get the rules going
with about five reps,
right?
You say,
okay,
this maybe no one's ever play peekaboo
with the baby and the baby figures it
out right away,
this,
and then you're very that.
Maybe do that.
That baby thinks that's a hell of a good
joke instead of down.
And so it's variations within this rule
bound theme.
It's kind of like musical in the sense,
right?
It's variations within the theme.
Now what you don't do is go
because the baby,
that was your shortage right now,
so you don't do that unless you're,
you know,
last year haven't evil streak.
So there's certainly ways of violating
the baby's expectations and what the
baby will do.
If you do that as startle and they
started with their whole bodies and then
look at you and then probably they'll
burst into tears,
but some babies will just laugh,
like mad if something like that happens.
And you can find those babies all over
youtube.
You get the baby,
the mother's sneezes and the baby has a
fit laughing for like 10 minutes,
you know?
So it's quite interesting,
like one of the things about babies I've
never been able to understand is the
staggering sophistication of their
senses of humor,
like and it's like it's deeper because
even a nine month old baby can play
tricks on you.
So you know,
their baby tricks but still their tricks
and they laugh and you know,
they're quite comical and they liked
variation.
So anyways,
the point is point.
One of the points of all this is these,
these,
this understanding of game like
structures is really,
really,
really deep inside of us.
And it's way before articulation.
You know,
Arctic,
it's way before we can say the rules.
Babies can pick up the damn rules right
away and it's kind of a dance.
Some sense.
And the dance is also a rule bound
structure.
Like if you're dancing with someone,
well there's rules like don't step on
their feet,
but you also set up a set of
expectations in the dance and then you
violate them in tandem.
And if you can do it gracefully then
it's fun.
You know,
and,
and maybe the person you're dancing
with,
configuring out if you were an absolute
Klutz and you know,
civil autistic that you can't even get
outside of yourself and might make a
half reasonable partner or if it's just
hopeless so,
but the dance is the same thing.
It's not negotiated verbally.
It's negotiated bodily and unless we
were able to imitate and imitate
insanely well because human beings can
imitate like mad,
we wouldn't be able to do that.
And so babies are the same way.
You basically start,
you don't actually.
Peekaboo doesn't have rules because a
rule is a stated description of a set of
expectations.
What,
what peekaboo has his expectations and
repetition and you can violate the
expectations,
but that doesn't mean you're breaking
the rule because the expectation is not
a rule.
It's not a rule until you observe the
expectation.
You describe what it is and maybe you
even write it down and you can play
games long before,
long before you can follow rules.
And one of the things piaget observed is
if you take kids,
if you watch a bunch of kids playing a
complicated game like marbles in,
they're like six and you take them out
of the game and you ask them what the
rules are,
they can't tell you or they may be get
some of them right in a bunch of them
wrong.
Maybe if you interviewed every child
that was playing and you looked at the
commonality of description,
you could extract out the underlying
rule structure of the game.
But the kids don't know the rules,
what they know is how to play with other
kids when they're playing marbles.
And a lot of that's,
you know,
nonverbal Hanson eyebrow raises and no,
you can't do that and so forth.
And it isn't till much later that they
can tell you the rules if ever.
So like,
you know,
you guys can't tell me the rules for
dancing successful with someone.
You can tell me some stupid things you
shouldn't do,
but you imagine how complex it is.
It's very,
very difficult to articulate the whole
structure.
But you can sure tell when it's
happening.
And you can sure tell when you're not
doing it or maybe your partner isn't.
So partly what that also means is you
know how to do things that you don't
know how you know how to do and you know
how to do all sorts of things that you
don't know how,
you know how to do in fact most of what
you notice like that.
And so that also means that we can be
playing games that are extraordinarily
sophisticated and that maybe are rooted
way back in history that we don't
understand.
But that doesn't mean that we can't
describe.
At least we don't have an articulated
knowledge of the structure,
but we could still play them.
Now,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but you might know it
a while back 20 years ago
about that,
those massive online multiplayer games
started to become popular.
And uh,
you know,
some of them I think although I don't
know this for sure,
some of them lasted a long time and
maybe some of them are still being
played like the early ones,
you know.
So they developed entire worlds in
there.
And you know,
um,
there was an economist who became quite
famous because of those games.
Castro Neva,
I think his name was Edward Castronova,
I think that's right.
But it's close.
Anyways,
he tried,
he thought,
hey look man,
those are games,
those are countries.
And so one of the things he tried to do
was to calculate their gross national
product and you know,
you can trade items in those little
worlds,
right.
And you could,
you could sell them on Ebay for example.
And for awhile in this one game and
maybe there's still happens,
there were young people in the
Philippines who are working inside these
games,
making artifacts that they were selling
on Ebay to other game players because
they could make more money doing that
than they could actually working in the
actual world.
Well,
so Castronova I think what's his name
said?
Well you don't get it.
That is the real world.
Like that's not a game or if it's a
game,
it's so much like the world that it's
part of the world.
And so he calculated the gross national
product of some of these massive games
and they were like,
the 30th richest country in the world
was insane,
you know,
and so that's interesting because that
also shows you that the line between a
game and reality is not clear.
So here's another example of that.
It's something we're thinking about.
Um,
some of you have no doubt played very
complex multiplayer online games and I
suppose those more often those are
adventure games or quest games and you
have to communicate with other people
and you have to solve problems and you
have to,
you know,
maybe you have to defend yourselves.
It's like you're an exploratory party in
a new world,
something like that.
And so it's pretty sophisticated now.
Okay.
And some of you have worked at
Mcdonald's or another fast food
restaurant.
How many of you have worked at a
restaurant?
Okay.
How many at a fast food restaurant?
Would you say that an online game is
more like the world or less like the
world then your job at a fast food
restaurant or more?
It's more.
Can anybody disagree?
Okay.
Why is it more like the real world
complex stuff,
but what are you doing?
You're exploring,
you're thinking,
you're getting out of situations.
You always,
every new situations coming up and
you're dealing with them and you're
learning a fast food,
right?
You're a real car.
Get fast food and the sheet,
right?
Yeah,
but it's in the real world.
Is it a gate and more like a machine.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
so does that mean that McDonald's is
less real than a multiplayer online
game?
Well,
it's a tough one a because when you're
trying to think about what real means
is,
you might think maybe I phrased that
wrongly,
I maybe I could say,
is Mcdonald's a worst model of the real
world than a multiplayer online game?
And it's too hard because it's hard to
say that dogs is part of the real world.
So like a priority to claim is kind of
absurd.
It's like,
well,
you're in a building.
People actually come there,
they give you money,
it's real.
But then when all you think about these
complex games and you think,
well,
you're practicing and extraordinarily
sophisticated forms of social and
intellectual behavior and we actually
don't know what that does to people.
Maybe it makes them extraordinarily
sophisticated than social.
I do think that it helps with introverts
quite a lot,
you know,
cause the introverts,
it's harder for introverts to become
extremely socially fluid because people
were the mount.
But a lot of introverts do a lot of
heavy duty socializing on the net.
And my experience has been that it's,
you know,
all things considered,
it's probably a plus rather than a
minus.
Um,
with regards to your,
your use of computational devices
because you grew up,
grew up with them.
One of the things I used to see my kids
doing is they would sit together in the
group,
they were teenagers and there'd be a
bunch of their friends that were there
and while they were interacting with all
their friends who were there,
they are also interacting with all their
friends who weren't there.
Is that a common thing for teenagers to
do?
Tech state.
You're texting your friends that aren't
there and so forth.
Is that reasonably standard behavior?
How many of you have done that?
Okay.
How many?
How many have you done that regularity?
Okay.
How many of you haven't done that?
So most people have done it,
but no one.
Everyone.
For those of you who have done it,
is that more advanced or less advanced
social behavior.
Okay.
You think more?
Why?
Because I'm like you're keeping your
friends while they're not there.
Okay.
Have a conceptual idea of like what
you're doing and like
understand where the dynamics are moving
without them actually having to be
there.
Okay.
Do you think that you paid a price for
it in the decrease of the intensity of
the social interactions you were having
with the people who were actually there?
You don't think so.
You think,
okay,
how many people think they do pay a
price for it?
Okay.
How many people think they didn't?
So.
Okay,
so,
well let's start with you guys then
because you're in a minority.
So why,
why do you think you didn't pay a price
for it?
Oh,
okay.
Well,
I think that can pay a price,
but if you're doing it correctly then
you're monitoring the conversation that
you're currently taking part of,
you know,
when it would be appropriate to your
phone and text someone else,
which actually meaningful probably
paying more attention to the people
you're talking about because you know,
you're also having to monitor.
Okay.
So that's your kind of taken a
multitasking
rationale for it.
Some sense.
Although assuming also that you have to
your attention to manage that is there
as people who,
who didn't think that it was,
that you did pay a price for who?
Who thought that?
Okay.
What sort of price?
I think that especially with text
gets lost,
convey your feelings.
Like there's so much more to.
Okay.
So they certainly lose something.
What about you while you're interacting
with like your,
your,
your actual president,
France.
I would say you have to commit to some
certain amount of effort to,
you know,
writing the textbook,
ignore like aspects of.
So for example,
if they're talking about something
and then you texted them when you come
back and miss like some.
Yeah.
So,
so it stopped.
Started stopped,
started.
I don't think you can commit yourself.
One of the things you've suggested was
that some of that can be mitigated by
doing it properly,
which which implies that there's an
emergent norm norm for doing this sort
of thing and that if you're good at
complying with the norm,
then you're not going to be irritating
people and maybe you can handle things
at once.
Something like that
to the people that are in there that's
waiting for you to answer.
Well,
I guess one answer to that would be
that's up to them to determine like if
they don't want a big part of it,
then they could go do something else and
the reason I'm saying that specifically
is because you can imagine that that's
how the norm develops.
It's like obviously if a successful norm
is going to develop that allows for text
conversation and real world
conversation,
do current the same time everybody has
to want it to happen and so that means
that you can't do it in the manner that
everyone wants.
It's going to die out.
Now,
see,
that's another example of,
of the sea.
That's another example of how you can
start thinking about how moral
structures might I think evolve is the
right way of thinking about them because
I think moral structure has evolved and
I think they're just as real as anything
else that evolves.
Now evolved things can be staggeringly
complex,
right?
I mean just think about how many life
forms there are and how many different
niches there are for those life forms
and so you have in some sense an
infinite variety,
but it's not infinite and it follows
patterns.
Not just any old thing can be alive and
not just any old thing can be social.
So here's an example.
I found this out a while back.
I did a lot of neuro biological
research.
Some of it hands on,
lot of conceptual,
especially in the early days of my
graduate work and I got really
interested in the function of Serotonin
and you know,
you all know undoubtedly that one of the
things that antidepressants do is
decrease the rate at which Serotonin is
pulled back up into the neurons that
deliver it.
And that seems to help stabilize
people's negative emotion.
Makes them less full of tile,
less anxious,
less likely to withdraw,
and so,
or you could say it makes them more
confident.
Now we also know that if you look,
say at a chimp hierarchy,
um,
if you take bottom chimp and you give
him antidepressants,
then he starts acting more like talk
chimp.
So because the bottom champ,
the bottom chimps world is a very
dangerous place.
It's very uncertain.
He doesn't have a very good place to
sleep.
He doesn't have high quality mates,
he doesn't have good things to eat.
He stressed man,
it's bad down there.
And so maybe that's part of the reason
his nervous system is tuned so that he's
more anxious and upset by everything
because everything actually is more
dangerous.
Part of that's modulated by Serotonin.
Okay?
So here's a rough rule.
If there's a hierarchy in an animal
kingdom at,
as you move up the hierarchy,
your serotonin levels increase and as
you move down the hierarchy or serotonin
levels decrease and that's somewhat
independent of your absolute wealth.
So here's the famous experiments called
the Whitehall experiment,
and it was done on English bureaucrats.
And the thing that's so cool about the
white doll experiments as they were done
50 years apart,
and so what they showed basically was so
imagine you take a English bureaucracy
and you stratify it by position,
you know Englishman or hierarchical and
so you stratified by position,
you have the top people in the bottom
people,
and then you look at the death rates and
what you find is the bottom people die
faster and more often now you might say,
well that's partly because if you're not
that healthy,
you end up at the bottom fair enough.
But there seems to be an effect over and
above the effect of just general health.
It's worse to be at the bottom that at
the top.
Okay.
That was true 70 years ago and then the
study was done again 50 years after
that.
Now the thing that's so cool,
it's been by that time,
from a material perspective,
the people who are at the bottom of the
modern hierarchy,
we're at least as wealthy roughly
speaking as the people who are like two
thirds of the way up 50 years before.
Right?
Because you know everybody had running
water.
That's a good thing.
Everyone,
everyone,
everyone had enough heat for the winter,
you know,
everyone had shelter and so on,
so you know when you figure with regards
to,
well,
once you've got running water,
reliable shelter,
heat and maybe air conditioning.
If you live in the desert and you're not
hungry,
it's like you've got 90 percent of what
wealth can deliver.
Oh really?
All things considered.
The rest of it is status and luxury
items,
but this,
the relationship between positional
status and death rates remain constant,
so that's.
That's very interesting and we know that
that's true from a lot of other studies
as well.
It's like control for absolute wealth.
There's still a problem with hierarchy
and that seems mediated,
at least in part by Serotonin and
serotonin regulates negative emotion and
the more negative emotion that you
experienced,
the more cortisol you produce.
Cortisol and high levels is toxic and it
suppresses your immune system so your
brain gets damaged and you.
You gain weight and you get diabetes and
maybe develop Alzheimer's disease and
you're more prone to cancer and heart
disease.
And all of those things,
and so that's just not so good now that
that serotonergic mechanism is really
old and so
you can give Serotonin,
new Jack injections to unhappy lobsters
and cheers them right up at least
behaviorally speaking.
If they're defeated in a fight and you
give them a serotonin dejection,
they'll stand up tall,
confident,
and they'll fight again.
Now the reason I'm telling you that for
a very specific reason,
because one of the things we've been
asking about as well,
how might you conceptualize moral
systems and then how might you
conceptualize their evolution.
And one of the propositions was there
are playable games and non playable
gates.
Well,
here's a playable game dominance
hierarchy.
We've been playing it for $400,
million years.
It's stable now.
It's,
it's,
it's so unstable that even lobsters have
them,
but even worse,
it's so stable that the biochemical
systems that the lobsters used to act
within the dominance hierarchy and react
to.
It's the same as it is in us.
And so not only is that stable,
it's,
well,
it's ridiculously stable.
So one of the things we could say is,
well,
one of the games that seems emergent and
real is a dominance heart.
Well then we might ask,
well what exactly constitutes a
dominance hierarchy?
And then we might also ask,
well,
what constitutes a highly functional
dominance hierarchy versus a
dysfunctional dominance hierarchy and
even what does highly functional versus
dysfunctional meet while we have to
define all those terms,
but we will as we move forward.
But you see the point I'm making is that
there,
and this is a bit of a contradiction
with the initial statement,
I need that there is a tight distinction
between the scientific world in the
objective world because I'm also talking
about the evolution of games and you
know,
evolution,
the study of evolution is obviously a
scientific study and the dominance
hierarchies a biological phenomena,
but in some sense it's also a game and
it's also a moral structure.
So there are levels of analysis where
these things start to get tangled
together and that's partly what we're
going to try to sort out.
So,
um,
we'll do that in the future because it's
very,
very complicated.
Alright,
now we're going to step back a little
bit.
Fact,
we're going to take a break.